pablo has been dealing coming off to
your point one of his best starts of the
season kyle schwarber in the top spot
and it's safe to say he's settled in
there he's been scuffling a bit
so first pitch and schwarber right side
base in
underway at 7 10.
now you can see the alignment right out
of the gate for the marlins everybody on
the right side of the field
almost like a pinball machine
kind of made its way to the top bounced
around a little bit and got through
that's just how he's been swinging it
right now next up 421 last 10 games
for trey turner
this one is chopped to short miggy jazz
over to first for the double play
zimmerman with soto at first two down no
score just underway top of the first at
lone depot park tonight the marlins and
the nats pitch to zimmerman is a ground
ball sharply hit right at rojas he's got
it goes a short way to second base they
get the force out there on soto so pablo
lopez able to blink the nationals in the
top of the first four lester is start
number 434 you go to those active
leaderboards and he's all over the place
two on and one out for adam duvall
craig is just checking in wants to make
sure you're okay certainly are and so is
adam duvall the base hit to left here
comes marty he will score
adam duvall gives the marlins a
one-nothing lead yeah aren't you glad
you stayed i am that's the lead we were
looking for
change up a little out front but kept
that barrel through the zone
we've seen this from duvall of late
the ability to pull into left field and
does it once again you can run on
schwarber schrover's a match here but he
does not have a great arm
they need a lead they've got themselves
a lead finally against the nationals and
now you look to get greedy and get a big
inning
3-1
and miggy rowe with a fly ball out to
left field backing up is schwarber and
that one is gone
run over for miguel rojas
and he's gonna go back and
touch first base there we go just to
make sure miguel rojas number four on
the season rbi's 17 18 and 19. it's been
a struggle for miggy since his stint on
the il that's gotta really feel good
four nothing marlins on top as we head
to the top of the third inning kyle
schwarber to lead things off
fastball
schwarber again
see
you
later
they keep trying to sneak the cheese by
this guy
and that's number 22 rbi number 50.
never seen a guy more locked in than
joshua what a power search ryan
zimmerman stands in now for the
nationals with turner at first base one
out marlins leading the nats 4-1 we're
in the top half of the third inning
up and in
turner no chance
that's number 16 for trey giving him the
league lead
zimmerman hammers one that'll score trey
turner
[Applause]
and the nats have cut the deficit in
half
4-2 ball game on ryan's 21st rbi
capping off a great at-bat two as
garrett cooper leads off against john
lester
garrett cooper will find the gap in left
center field and this one will head to
the wall
garrett cooper cruises into second with
a lead-off double
gail rojas a three run home run his
first time up
payoff pitch miggy left field base hit
cooper coming around third he's going to
score on his way to third duvall
and miguel rojas adds another rbi
marlins back in front by three
sanchez gets a crack at john lester with
men at the corner still nobody out
and now sanchez with a flying ball left
field deep and off the base of the wall
duval is going to score maggie is held
up at third on the rbi double from jesus
sanchez swing was a deep fly ball in the
first inning very similar approach
worked ahead in the count but nothing
about the swing is telling you yeah i
got to get out in front i'm going to
look to pull
why would you jon lester he works away
from lefties 75 of the time
bertie has to understand when you talk
about situational awareness it's up to
him to find a way to get at least one of
these runs if not both of them in
right up the middle
and into center field for a base hit
sanchez almost ran through the stop sign
and has to hustle back to third
when i say almost ran through the stop
sign i mean literally almost ran through
trey hillman cooper has been on base
twice
a walk and a run scored in the first a
double and a run scored in the third
a big welcome back for coop
it may not be done scorches one out to
right field and that's off the base of
the wall on his way to second soto's
throw a little off the mark two doubles
for garrett cooper's first game off the
il cooper at third duval at second roll
house at first one out marlins up 7-2
looking to bust this one wide open
brown bald is short
turner goes to second for one on the
first but he beats it out and that'll be
another run
here's jazz over 3-2 strikeouts one
marlon hasn't gotten into the fun here
tonight
2-2
jazz ground ball vacated left side
birdie coming around third he's going to
score easily in jazz chisholm jr
has driven in a run turner playing him
up the middle as if
jazz won't go the other way i mean this
is a hard hit ground ball to short
partner how many times have we seen this
base hit for jazz this year i mean just
an easy drive hard hit through the left
side because there's nobody there
he is more than willing to go the other
way and pick up birdie garrett cooper's
had a big night walked and scored in the
first doubleton scored in the third
doubled and scored in the fourth two for
three tonight
see the dodgers on the next home stand
as garrett cooper sends one out to left
center field oh boy what a day off the
il and on fire
now super cooper duper you're back how
about it impressive ball game as anthony
bass takes over his 32nd game for the
marlins
robles out to left sanchez underneath it
he will make the catch it's a marlins
win a big one 11-2 tonight
offense early and often and a strong
start from pablo lopez he was terrific
a complete team win here for miggy rowe
and the marlins tonight